one of the characteristic things that
makes a problem-solving question a
problem-solving question is that they
give you words and it's your job to
translate that into our side so let's
read at a certain time of the day a post
full metres tall okay a post there we go
here's my vertical push four metres tall
right
I have a right angle in there because
four meters is straight up okay
otherwise we wouldn't say I was probably
this tall would say all these long it
casts a shadow of 1.8 meters he's the
shadow 1.8 meters okay so it's cast a
shadow on the ground what is the angle
of elevation oh that's an important
phrase angle of elevation that's why
we're doing them what is the angle of
elevation of the Sun at that time all
right let's have a look at this now
angle elevation you know it's an angle
and the diagram gives you actually this
calls that theta okay now it actually
makes sense when you think about the
phrase angle of elevation elevation
elevate is what does elevate mean it
means go up that's all it means right so
you've got this angle from the
horizontal and you look up that's all it
means
angle of elevation okay you're looking
up at something now even though it's not
in this particular question the angle of
elevation has a poorer
sadder brother which happens when you
don't look up at something when you look
down at something and it's called an
angle of depression okay so so for
instance if up if you were the Sun right
look easy out of the post there would be
an angle of depression up there again
it's measured from the horizontal okay
and then you would look downwards like
so okay
it depends again on the language of the
question right so if I had phrased it
okay let's see you would say you taste
of the bike from the point of view of
the Sun or you know some guy on a cliff
or on the top of a building or something
like that right you use give a point of
reference and then they would say an
angular elevation or an angular
depression okay and that tells you up or
down simple stuff all right
now that's the scenario that's that's
all they give us in the question okay so
now you have to pretty some of the
position in the game what do I know
about this and what do i do I treat all
the tree in general that can help me
okay good
instinctively you as soon as you see a
triangle right you want to think okay
I've got sides here I've got some of
them and they're going to give me some
useful information right so you're
standing at this angle up here sorry
down there I'm gonna get rid of this one
since it's just you standing out here
right so these two sides in relation to
that angle are I've got the opposite one
which one's the opposite one for meters
opposite all the way over there and
adjacent doing is 1.8 is right next to
theta okay so now you are signed to get
to the point after like a week at a bit
do to say Oh opposite adjacent I know
it's ratio that is that's 10 good so now
I'm going to write an equation I'm gonna
say 10 feet up and that's the angle that
I'm after okay 10 theta is opposite on
adjacent opposite on adjacent like so
and we only what the angle that's all we
need to do okay so in this case to
remember you'll need your calculator for
this part we need to take it sorry god
this one no next one okay because this
is Ted you got tear there on the right
hand middle of your calculator right so
to get theta you take tan inverse of
whatever was on that side okay by the
way you guys know how I talk about
sometimes it's really useful to put down
working even though it's not necessary
to get marks whatever I think it's
really important to write down this line
I think is essential okay because it
guides what you're putting into your
calculator right so you put you at any
of us for over 1.8 they've asked for
actually they don't ask for any accuracy
so let's just write out the full video
calculator says degrees okay so they go
right now let's just do a bit of
practice here a pretty standard sort of
thing would be to say nearest degree
degree so what would this be equal to to
the nearest degree just sister-sister
just round up 66 degrees to the nearest
degree okay but you know maybe they want
it to be a little more accurate if we
had to round off to say one decimal
place what would it be sixty five five
point now this this is the the first
estimate and it goes up goes up right
that seven is gonna go up to eight right
so it will be sixty five point eight
degrees if it was to the nearest one
decimal place